des répliques cultes tu as trois mois
jour pour jour top chrono
avec combien de temps le grand art un
casting cinq étoiles moi j'ai fait césar
parce qu'en fait c'est monica bellucci
café cléopâtre et une bonne dose
d'effets spéciaux astérix et obélix
mission cléopâtre c'était il ya vingt
ans sortie le 30 janvier 2002 au cinéma
énorme c'est vraiment le film de l'année
budget 50 millions d'euros un record
pour un film français à l'époque sans
compter les milliers de figurants et 22
semaines de tournage en partie dans le
désert marocain sous une chaleur
étouffante
pas facile pour gérard darmon qui campe
le rôle du méchant à mon beau-fils 14
heures dans le désert à ouarzazate en
plein mois de jeûne c'est quoi il
faisait 45 sous la tente de césarée mais
de l'opium cottage en voilà une équipe
de cinéma les projos les flambeaux
c'était infernal en plus de la chaleur
le réalisateur alain chabat a dû faire
face à quelques imprévus c'est pas des
mauvais souvenirs mais c'est vrai que
j'ai dirigé une ou deux scènes des
chiottes parce que je m'étais pris une
vraie bonne tourista et donc je suis
auto qui 1 dans les chiottes assis sur
le moniteur de contrôle même pas en tête
d'affiche christian clavier en astérix
et gérard depardieu en obélix et bien
sûr l'humoriste jamel debbouze qui tient
le rôle de l'architecte numérobis la
bogossitude et a pu enfin le regard
acariâtre le lien qu'il un la bouche
charnue rancel gros sans oublier monica
bellucci dans la peau de la reine
cléopâtre c'est une cause unique le
patron peu
exagéré
et là un côté très nerveux mais mais
mais quand les et les durées les jeux
mais vraiment méchante vingt ans après
sa sortie astérix et obélix mission
cléopâtre est considérée comme une
comédie culte à l'époque le film a été
un énorme succès avec plus de 14
millions d'entrées
[Musique]